hey um I'd love to start from the
beginning of little America when did it
first start as an epic magazine project
and was the first spark that it could
make a TV show well Lee and I are old
pals very very old pals and he called a
and you know and we do stories that go
off and work and you know get adapted
for film and TV and sometimes a producer
writer likely will call and say I've got
this idea maybe it can be enlivened by
true stories so that's what happened and
he cons that I want to do an intelligent
about immigrants can we find real people
and and see what that inspires for a
show so we sent a bunch of writers and
journalists around the country scouring
the nation for different stories and
brought those back and leave what we're
seeing them the whole time and getting a
sense of what the show was and it was
just very clear once way the stories
like Oh everything we need is in here
this is a this is a great diverse set of
stories that can make exactly the show
that we imagined yeah what do you think
of some of these strengths from an
anthology series versus a series that
follows maybe one main character I think
that was really exciting for us to tell
parts of people's lives and rather than
kind of follow someone's entire journey
we're kind of pulling snapshots here and
there and that the kind of the mosaic of
all of those stories is this show that
the the breadth of our country the
breadth of diversity and and the breadth
of the storytelling is what makes the
show special to me and I think that if
we can surprise the audience with this
one is in the United States for three
minutes and this one there is no sound
there's there's plenty of sound there's
no dialogue and the one that Sean wrote
and directed I think that that's I think
that's what's exciting about in the
thought anthology series is you feel the
tone hopefully from episode to episode
feels similar it feels of a piece but
within that you're playing around with
form and playing around with structure
and you're also introducing such a
variety of characters yeah and it gives
a huge amount of freedom to the writer
and director to almost create their own
little film like it doesn't have to be
tight you know the shooting style could
be different
energy the time spans could be different
and I think I had an experience watching
the show because I think when we made it
you know we're all in it and you're
working on it every day and you're like
is it good I don't know we're doing it
and just like the show coming out and
sitting back and watching it I and
really imagining myself just as an
audience member and not someone who
knows all the trials and tribulations
along the way like the tapestry of faces
and the breath of following these
different stories that all take place in
these different parts of the country and
over you know someone's a different age
or gender
it was quite powerful to see that as a
tapestry of like this is what our
country looks like like let's not forget
that this is this actually is what
America is is all of these different
people and their little human
experiences that are happening in cities
or towns and we just chose to like shine
a spotlight on that person for this one
moment and that feels cool I also think
that it kind of made me weirdly when I
watch the show it kind of makes me fall
in love with America again in a
nostalgic way like the music Zac cow is
our music supervisor yeah credible real
nerd about overall music but but also
just the songs that he put in that kind
of capture a time in a place in the
States and seeing some of these wide
shots of horses here then you see snow
here like the country is gigantic and
there's so many different places for us
to touch and I thought that was just
really exciting and and and also just
being introduced to all this amazing
world music and falling in love with
like a Persian singer from the 70s and
falling over the like jadoo sisters one
of whom just passed away from Nigeria I
mean that all these things just kind of
it was just exciting it was it was an
exciting thing both creating it and then
sitting back and watching it and seeing
it all kind of come together because
there's so many different there's so
many different pieces to make a show
like this yeah I think tab streets the
exact right word I'm glad you brought up
the silence I thought that was such an
engaging interesting episode I love that
episode what what where did the initial
idea to make it without dialogue come
from and what were some of the fun
challenges on set shooting it well I
think it's challenging not only was it a
silent in silence but it was a silent
retreat where people are just sitting
there in a room so I think the challenge
but where's the action it's like what
happens like you know and even when I
talked
mana who was the subject who was based
on she was like I mean we just sat all
day long every day and so to try to go
like well what was your brain doing
while you sat there and so some of those
things that she just mentioned in our
conversations like oh my god monkey mind
and you struggle with monkey mind I'm
like monkeys maybe I'll get a real
monkey in the episode so I kept Azores
is designed cuz Shawn wanted to meet a
monkey sure there were several monkeys
narrowed it down to just one that was
the highlight of my life was but I think
yeah it was it was a challenge to sort
of find like what was the humor how do
you capture how do you connect with
someone when you they can't ever voice
you know can't ever really know them so
how can we use this episode and like
through the other characters and these
very small interactions or moments get
to know this person and I think weirdly
that episode became almost like a
metaphor for what it's like to come to
the u.s. you know to be a stranger in a
strange land to be an outsider where
everything feels kind of off and weird
and and you're looking for key clues and
human behavior as to how you're supposed
to be and I think that episode was kind
of the quirky weird one but then it
almost became like a metaphor for like
the immigrant experience in general and
the irony that like no one knows she's
an immigrant until the end when she
speaks and so in a way the silence is an
equalizer like their silence is the
universal language and then you realize
how difficult it is for her to be an
immigrant in the in the US and so she
gets to make this love connection purely
on a human and physical basis which like
if only we could all get back to that
point and not have communication and
words and differences get in the way of
finding connection making that episode
was a little bit like going to a sound
retreat where it seems like a really
good idea
this is really hard because we did sort
of backup my girlfriend actually told me
that story that's her friend's mother
and I told it to Lee and so the whole
thing was always built up like it's so
funny it's so weird you know it's silent
and then at the very end they've had
this whole romance and then realize like
oh they don't speak the same language so
we're always drawn to this kind of like
how it all went to this point but then
as as shown in there were talking about
then we had to figure out what does that
actually mean how do you make that into
something and then through painful work
like at a sound retreat a meaning arose
and so it's also a metaphor for itself I
think with that episode there was
actually more dialogue and we kept
stripping it away yeah terrified it's
like you can't do an episode I mean the
first draft of that script was had the
least dialogue of anything that anyone I
knew had ever been a part of so it
wasn't like everybody but Lee was too I
wasn't right yeah Zachary Quinto who's
the biggest star probably that we have
in season one had lots of lines of
dialogue it was kind of guiding the
audience and guiding the people at the
silent retreat through their meditation
and then we took away all the four lines
of dialogue from him and I don't know
that he would have signed out to do it
in the first place but he brought he
likes it to call back and be like well
first of all to Lee and Alan Yang's
credit they were the ones who was really
pushing I was like I don't know if an
audience is gonna go with this if we
take out all right language and they
were like let's just do it let's just be
bold and it was exciting to have that
freedom as a filmmaker to feel like
let's just do it but yes I totally had
to call Zak and be like all of your lame
jersey and like there was that monkey
and the monkeys in your lines are
monkeys in the monkey is the big
monologue at the end yes he's playing
Spock in the next video cases your
physical abilities you're yeah yeah it
felt very freeing as an audience member
to watch too especially that sort of
tone shift at the very end
are there any kind of tones you're
interested in exploring in season two
I think that we can't like you don't
want the show to feel like a gimmick you
don't want to do every single episode
has kind of like right this is the twist
uh but I think that they're like we're
talking about doing an episode that's
set in 1832
and I think that there's so many
different versions of immigrant stories
and it's up to us and the researchers
and the writers to kind of say like okay
well what would that look like and how
and then the poor production people that
are like what do you mean 1832 no more
monkeys New York Harbor here right
anyway so yeah I mean the show the show
is logistically ambitious and I just
want every episode to stand on its own
and that you when you watch little
America you're excited because you feel
like okay there's a certain level of
storytelling and that you connect with
the characters a certain way but with
from within that you don't know what
we're gonna do like oh you think the
character is this thing and well a lot
of what we've actually been talking
about in season two is you start a
character in a place where you're like
oh I understand this is a story about X
and then within a scene you're somewhere
else yeah I guess finally this kind of a
fraught discourse going on about America
right now what do you think this I hate
to be the one to bear the bad news um
what do you think this shows thesis
statement about America is I mean I
think we all roughly agree that the show
is trying is representing what we sort
of you know the highest ideals of
America right that it's a inclusive
place that it's a plurality that it's a
place that anybody can find refuge in
you know sort of be themselves that was
part of the you know animating idea of
the show at the beginning and I think
that at times when we were doing this I
sort of felt like are we being naive is
this not really America anymore do we've
sort of telling a false story but I
don't think that's the case I think that
the ideals are very sturdy and will sort
of outlast whatever political moments we
have and then the show speaks to that it
explains a little like why is it sort of
like creates the notion of America
is totally lasting I also think that
there's this narrative you know without
art like this it's like there are
rapists crossing the border and people
are invading your country and it's it's
terrifying and I think that I I
understand I understand why that exists
but every one of those people every one
of those immigrants they all have a
story and I think that when whether or
not you're an immigrant or the child of
an immigrant when you see that when you
see yourself in a character you see
yourself in someone that's not like you
I think there's like really powerful
about that and I think that that's
something worthy of being seen and being
talked about and I don't think we never
set out to make the show political but I
think the fact that we're talking about
it and the fact that you're asking that
question is exciting and that that's
that needs to be part of the
conversation and that when you look at
when you look at someone on the street
who doesn't look like you know that
they're kind of they want the same stuff
that you want I also think there's
something about taking a word that has
become very loaded like immigrant or
immigration or you know and I worked on
orange is the new black for many years
and like we're sort of doing the same
thing with prisoners and the idea of
like people have an idea of like who
people are that are in jail but like if
you just focus on one person and you
stop trying to tell the story about
everyone and you just tell one story and
it's you know having to immigrant
parents that had very different stories
and came from different places you know
my dad was a refugee who was escaping
for his life and my mom came to go to
art school because she wanted freedom to
be an artist and like there are all
different reasons that people come here
and this country is still a place where
people can invent themselves and be
themselves and I think just reminding
everyone of like take away the power
from that word take away whatever is on
that word and let's just understand that
all that means is someone who came here
from somewhere else and they're a human
being just like you and I think that
that's really that was a long